[Applause]
[Music]
hi i'm christopher hein and this week
we're talking about filling in all the
missing gaps in aikido so
i think that most aikido people are
pretty clear about what the techniques
are and how to do the techniques and
and people have good ideas about what
the main philosophies of aikido are
but how do we fill in all that area in
between that allows our techniques to
to facilitate our our our philosophy
and how our philosophy is represented by
those techniques
we've already talked about all the
middle stuff and so you know the basic
uh arrangement i use in my approach to
aikido is that first there's a
philosophy and then a set of goals that
allow us to know if we're achieving our
philosophy or not
and then below that is the set of
tactics and the tactics start to
represent our strategy the the
systematic approach that we have
in order to achieve those goals and then
below that we have
techniques and so let's talk real quick
about just what a technique is in
general and then we'll kind of talk
about what the techniques are in aikido
and how those
help us with our tactics which is really
important so it's important to
understand that everything you do in
your life
you have a technique for at least
anything that you've done
a few times right you have a technique
and what the technique does is enables
you to do something in a really
efficient manner right so i remember one
time i became obsessed with
the technique i used to button my shirt
in the morning right and i realized that
there were probably about five or six
different ways to
to actually push the button through the
hole and button my shirt and that there
were different techniques and i didn't
use the other techniques and why didn't
i use them and why did i feel
that the technique i used to button my
shirt in the morning was was really
important
and that sounds like a weird thing but
the reason i got so obsessed with it is
because i realized that
uh martial arts techniques are just the
same kind of thing right
there might be a lot of ways to achieve
uh
something but this this shortened
version of it is the one that i find
ideal and why do i find it ideal
so that's basically what a technique is
and techniques are practiced and made to
be
something that it doesn't require a lot
of conscious thought now the reason for
this is because
conscious thought takes a lot of time
right so it doesn't seem like this to us
because
we we think from the conscious mind so
we think that oh you know i think pretty
fast but your
your unconscious reactions are actually
significantly faster than your conscious
reactions
so for example if you were to touch a
stove you don't have to touch it and say
oh that's hot i think that's going to
burn my hand and i'm going to pull it
away
in fact you really have almost zero
conscious thought you touch a hot stove
and your hand gets retracted
that's because your unconscious mind has
a really
well good technique produced which is to
pull that hand back as fast as possible
right
so techniques are training of the
unconscious mind so we want our
unconscious mind to do an
action in a really quick way and so we
don't want to be have the conscious mind
interfering with that
now when we're developing those and the
process of training is actually to
figure out what the best kind of
techniques are and how we can train
those to be as efficient with them as
possible and so
when we're talking about something like
a code guys you're you're training your
body to just
do a kodagash without you having to
think through the steps every time
now when you're a beginner of course you
have to think through the steps but as
you become more proficient
you will learn how to do it
unconsciously really quickly and with
really well
in fact i often laugh at some of my
senior students who haven't done a lot
of teaching because
when they're trying to explain to a new
person how to do something
they'll always say oh hang on and then
they'll just do it real quick and
they'll they'll consciously observe
themselves doing it
and then they can think oh yeah okay
that's what i do right and this is true
of any good technique it becomes
so natural to you that is your
unconscious mind doing it entirely and
your conscious mind really doesn't
become involved now that's ideal because
it's really fast and
conflicts generally really fast right so
something threatening and violent coming
at us is happening fast so
we have to have a set of techniques that
can do those things really fast
now examples of techniques in aikido so
techniques could be anything but what we
generally call the techniques in aikido
are confined to a few certain areas
one grouping i call the kyowasa kyo
means principle or lesson in japanese
and these are things like ikkyo
nikkiosankyo
gokyo and rokyo right so the six
principal lessons of aikido
and these have to do with controlling
the arms in certain ways twisting the
wrist in certain ways
these kinds of things methods to grab so
this is what the kill was
is they're a real important set of
principles that we kind of can't take
out of
achieving any of the the the tactical
ideals we'll want in aikida
so that's the keowaza then we also have
the nagewaza so these are things like
kokunage
nage shionage nagi koshinaga etc so
forth
these are the projection methods the
ways that we project something away from
us right so
how do we make something move away from
us so something's on us how do we make
it move away
then we have the osekomiwaza which are
the pins so how do we hold something
down and that might sound like it's
actually contrary to aikido
theory as i describe it but i'll explain
real quick as to how that works out but
the the pinning methods how do we hold
someone down or trap someone in some way
then we have the atemi waza how do we
strike stuff
and that could be armed or unarmed right
so it could be you know i'm just
popping someone real quick to get them
away or i've drawn a weapon and i'm
using a weapon to get someone away
and the hidoki wasa how i escaped from
from someone holding me so if someone's
got me in some way how do i become
disentangled from them and that's what
hodoki actually means
so how do i disentangle myself from
someone and bukiwaza so the bukiwaza is
the weapon technique so what if we get
in a situation where we got to do some
kind of weapon techniques right i need
to use a weapon i'm forced to use a
weapon to defend myself which also in
some ways might sound
contrary to aikido philosophy but is a
part of it and the doriwaza which is how
do we hold stuff and
the door he was also includes how do we
take something away from someone right
so how would i take a weapon away from
someone if someone was trying to attack
me
so those are the the regular techniques
in in my approach aikido we call those
kumiuchi
and those are struggle methods right so
they're the ways we struggle
now ideally i could we don't want to
struggle we want to make a chords we
want to make
some kind of negotiation that doesn't
require us to struggle at all
but sometimes the the struggle's
unavoidable
and so all of these things fall into a
lower level set of
tactics and um these lower level set of
tactics is generally what we call the
techniques of aikido
now those are all essential things right
so for example i would like someone to
never be able to grab me in fact if
someone grabs me
i've already lost my first three goals
right so
i wasn't ahead enough to keep them from
grabbing me i wasn't far enough away
that they
they wouldn't grab me and also my
position
it was bad one because they've got me
and then once they've got me i'm
probably not going to be able to easily
get to the position i want so
so someone grabbing me is really not
what i want
now unfortunately in aikido we think in
order to do aikido we've got to let
someone grab us first
so that's a real problem right
now unfortunately in aikido we think in
order to do aikido we've got to let
someone grab us first
so that's a real problem right so that's
part of why we can't really achieve our
philosophy is because
we think that those low level tactics
which are important they're very
important to the system
we think those low level tactics are
what aikido is
but instead they're just they're what we
do when we can't do anything else so
they're included in the system but
they're not the ideal
right and there's a lot of stuff of you
issue but talking about how the
techniques and the forms are not really
important right so
there's something to practice and help
you kind of learn the way of aikido but
they're not they're not the ideal right
they are useful though and i train my
students in them all the time and we
spend a lot of time working on them and
especially fourth q third queue we
really want them to have good clean
techniques since reason because
those techniques those low level tactics
can help reset us to the higher level
tactics
which can then make us meet our goals
which once we're meeting our goals and
we're achieving our aikido philosophy
so why are those what they are well the
kilwaza is set of
a set of very important principles that
we'll use no matter what once someone is
starting to come into contact with us
we're going to use those constantly all
the time we're constantly going to be
using those and that's because
people are going to get a hold of us and
things like ikkyo and nico and sankyo
and yonkyo all of them uh they can help
us get free
um also if someone was to um
have a weapon and try to get us dory
waza will also require
kyouwaza right so in order to get
something out of someone's hand we're
gonna need to know the lessons of the
kyowaza
in order to make good hadoki i have to
know the kielwaza
the kyowaza is really essential to all
of our basic struggle methods so that's
why they're the principles because those
six principles
will help us with everything else the
nagewaza is really important because
if i've lost my first three main goals
and someone's next to me
i want to be able to project them away
from me so i can then start using my
higher level tactics so if i can move
someone away from me
and don't think a throw just has to be
smashing someone into the ground that's
not the goal
uh projections in aikido are just to
move someone away so
no one has to fall down if they just
stumble off of me well then i've got
some distance again and i'm achieving
one of my goals right so
i'm then working from a higher uh higher
position of tactics right so i'm using
better tactics instead of having to use
the lower level tactics so
if someone's next to me and i can
project them away that's why we need
nage was it help
reset to get to those higher level
tactics pinning techniques now this
one's a
one fun one to talk about because i
think it seems like
that would be antithesis of the
philosophy of aikido right so
so if i'm pinning someone i very
actively am in direct physical contact
with them so which means if they're a
lot stronger than me
well then i'm not going to be able to
hold them very well also i have to be
close to them to pin them so that's not
achieving a main goal
i'm going to have all kinds of problems
are going to happen from this right so
it's important to understand that's a
low level tactic now why might i need
that low level tactic well
i got to get someone disarmed because
they're dangerous
and so in that situation i need to get
them into a controlled position on the
ground so i can get the weapon away from
them
or that someone who's potentially going
to hurt themselves
or someone else if i don't control them
right so meaning that you know
if i don't control that person they're
maybe they're insane or something
they're going to run off a cliff or do
something crazy or run into a burning
building or who knows what
or hit someone or hurt someone else that
doesn't need to get hurt so
so pins will be useful but the way in
which we pin an aikido
always starts to reset us to our three
main
goals right so it always take us
tactically up now the reason it does
this is because
we don't pin body to body in aikido we
always pin
off to the side so that means we put a
premium on autonomy the ability to be
free
and we don't put a premium on control
and security which is what
um other systems of jiu jitsu and stuff
do they put a premium on that security
absolutely we want to hold them no
matter what but in aikido we give up a
little bit of security
for the ability to be autonomous and
that means that if it's not working out
right if so if they're stronger than us
or
more people come to attack us or
whatever we can always bail out of that
really easy and reset
to the three main goals so that's how
pinning plays out in aikido the way we
pin is really important it's important
to understand that we don't we don't pin
like you would in other jiu jitsu styles
and the reason we do that
is because autonomy is one of our number
one goals so that's why we have pins
why do we have weapons in aikido and why
do we have strikes so the itemiwaza and
the buki was both kind of fall in this
category
well sometimes we'll have no choice
but to hit someone or use a weapon on
someone because they put us in such a
bad situation that not doing that means
that it will cost us our lives or or
will be controlled or seriously in
danger right
so that's not ideal again it's not our
top level tactics it's
very low and so we've already made a lot
of failures at this point
so we had to use a weapon or we had to
hit someone in a severe way
in order to get them off of us so we
could start to work up to our higher
tactics again so that's why we have
weapons there are situations where we're
just we have to have some kind of power
and weapons can give us that in order to
get out of them now it's not ideal it's
not good aikido and when we use a weapon
in aikido we always call it the ikea kin
or the ik joe and that's because we're
we're being reminded that
it's not about using the weapon to get
the other person it's about achieving
our higher level goals
and so the weapon might facilitate us to
get back to our higher level goals but
the weapon isn't a means unto itself
right it's just a tool to help us get
back to our upper level stuff
right the the dory was pretty pretty
simple to explain sometimes we'll need
to hold people and sometimes we'll need
to take weapons from people
um and the timmy was it kind of falls in
there with the buki waza so
understanding why these techniques are
what they are is very important and
those techniques are very good and
you'll need them if you get into a bad
situation
but they're very far from our ideal
strat
our ideal philosophy and so what the
strategy of aikido is telling us to do
is always get away from those low level
tactics
and start to work at the high level
tactics and then once we work at those
high level tactics
we can be regularly achieving our ideal
goals and if we're making our goals
then we're achieving the philosophy of
aikido so this is the progression i use
in my approach to aikido i hope it kind
of helps you think about aikido and what
it is and
and the pieces that are maybe missing in
aikido um and maybe kind of start to
suss those out for yourself
i appreciate your time watching this i'm
christopher hine thanks a lot